some stars have won Oscars in the past
summer won Emmys
to present the second award tonight
there is a versatile actress who's won
both an Oscar and an Emmy miss Shelley
Winters
thank you very much Bob but you know
actually I won two Oscars but then who's
counting tonight I am I know isn't it
odd that I won Miami on your Chrysler
Show that's what hurts
you know on this not last year I was
beside myself with excitement because I
was a nominee and tonight I'm just
beside myself because I'm not I'm really
delighted to be back here and to give
the award to the talented man who gave
the best performance by an actor in a
supporting role the nominees are James
Mason in Georgia girl George Segal and
Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf Robert
Shaw in a man for all seasons buckle in
the sand pebbles and Walter Matthau in
the fortune cookie may I have the
envelope mister me thank you
the winner is Walter Matthau
you had a tough time getting here
thank you the other day as I was falling
off my bicycle
I had the following thoughts I was given
a very juicy part I was allowed to work
with talented exhilarating and beautiful
people I was given a good deal of money
and a great deal of joy and now really
don't you think this is going a little
too far thank you